Chỉ gai sĩn pin của mình cho biết ngày của y quốc đời
Nc ai vẫn hoài mẹ ăn cương chương trường
Dạng người thân trần soch mẹ ra
Bình lông mắc khoảng
Tụi thơ mà
Cống đi cập có rồi
Đến dơ người dắt luôn
Còn đi đầm hộ lắm
Nó hà mọng lắm
Cớ nhầy mà
Đi như dụi dụi
Còn em tập giáo chế mấy
Đến ngày mất nó cũng vọng phòng giấu sự quan thằng
Mất sảo dân khóc và
Nó không bỏ được chân người này nóng lo được chân người kia
Nó nghĩ trường tá không?
thì bạn đứt má chơi đầy
thang bạc bạc
mà cho mác cơm chương
Là lúc nào lúc xin gõi xin đi
lúc đó
chắc hấp hệ
em nghe xong trình vậy
trình cà
bà YouTube mò người
chứ trọng lưỡng lưỡng tội
bà YouTube trọng em nhỏ
dựa nghe
Ê tem lần đầu tiên hoặc ra.
Hôm nay em đó đi là một mặt mặt b纜 tớ đận về số nước cho
một mặt lớn cho cho đận Gỳ người đã từng đi càng
Mong em đi phần thà, và tử gì vào diameter.